y
el ex presidente estadounidense donald
trump se negó a declarar este miércoles
frente a la fiscal general de nueva
york- trump está investigado por sus
prácticas comerciales el negocio
inmobiliario de su familia el ex
mandatario denuncia una persecución en
su contra
españa comenzó a aplicar este miércoles
el decreto para cumplir el ahorro
energético pactado con la unión europea
las medidas incluyen el apagón de
vitrinas y edificios públicos desde las
10 de la noche así como la rebaja de la
refrigeración en empresas y dependencias
públicas a los 27 grados en verano
tendremos reportes
al menos 13 personas murieron después de
un bombardeo durante la noche en la
región ucraniana de dnipropetrovsk
nikoláy quizá polillas son también
objetivos del ejército ruso además los
ministros de exteriores del g7 pidieron
a rusia que se retire de la planta
nuclear de zamorilla
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 6 rodrigo se dan hoy es un
gusto acompañarlos comenzamos este
informativo en eeuu el ex presidente de
donald trump informó que se negó a
declarar este miércoles frente a la
fiscal general de nueva york letitia
james es la encargada de la
investigación civil sobre sus prácticas
comerciales y el negocio inmobiliario de
su familia nuestra corresponsal en nueva
york mamen sadam no es amplia
si el exmandatario ha llegado a primera
hora de la mañana este edificio que
estáis viendo detrás de mí que se
encuentran las oficinas del fiscal
general de nueva york allí se ha acogido
a la quinta enmienda que le da derecho a
no declarar para autoinculparse ante las
preguntas ante el interrogatorio del
fiscal general de nueva york que
investiga un posible fraude fiscal
financiero en las empresas de la familia
trump al parecer esta investigación
civil se está centrando en que la
compañía trans podría haber engañado
acerca del valor de sus activos
engañando a prestamistas y a las
autoridades fiscales de nueva york a lo
largo de esta investigación ya han
declarado los hijos de donald trump pero
el exmandatario es una cita que hacía
meses que trataba de retrasar la última
vez que se retrasó fue precisamente
cuando falleció la primera mujer de
donald tram iban a tram esto fue a
mediados de julio pero hoy ha tenido que
venir aquí a prestar declaración se
esperaba que fuese una declaración que
durará horas pero se ha solucionado al
final en un minuto porque como digo se
ha acogido a ese derecho a la quinta
enmienda algo por lo que muchos medios
de comunicación le han criticado porque
él mismo en el 2016 en un mitin de
campaña dijo que no entendía por qué si
alguien era inocente se acogía a la
quinta enmienda pues bien hoy en un
largo comunicado en el que ha explicado
que se había acogido a la quinta
enmienda y por qué lo había hecho dice
que ahora lo entiende que cuando tu
familia y tus empresas familiares están
siendo objetivo de una caza de brujas no
te queda más remedio que hacer eso desde
luego está siendo una semana muy
complicada a nivel liga legal para el ex
mandatario después de que el fbi
registrará su mansión en florida y
además no olvidemos que tiene otra causa
penal abierta que está siendo
investigada por el fiscal del distrito
de manhattan
vamos a asia concretamente al estrecho
de formosa porque el ejército chino
aseguró que completó con éxito varias
tareas en taiwán después de una semana
de ejercicios militares con fuego real
sin embargo advirtió que seguirán
realizando patrullas regulares al tiempo
el ministerio de defensa taiwanés dijo
que hoy 17 aviones de combate chinos
cruzaron la línea del estrecho china
reiteró que no renunciara al uso de la
fuerza y que tomara las medidas
necesarias para defenderse de fuerzas
extranjeras y de las actividades
separatistas
hablamos ahora de la guerra en ucrania
donde al menos 13 personas murieron
después de un bombardeo durante la noche
en la región central del cni pro petrox
según las autoridades el ataque dañó más
de 20 edificios y miles de personas se
quedaron sin electricidad otras 6
personas murieron en un ataque ruso a
bach mut en el este de ucrania según
informó el propio gobernador de la
región nikolái y zap orilla también han
recibido ataques recientes rusos y el g7
le pide a las tropas de moscú que se
retiren de la planta nuclear más grande
de europa para evitar una catástrofe
radioactiva para toda la región juan
pabló lucumí nos cuenta más
luego de un toque de queda de 54 horas
los residentes de mico life salen a
recibir agua y alimentos
teniendo en cuenta la situación en la
ciudad cada ciudadano necesita algún
tipo de ayuda actualmente hay unas
150.000 personas en la ciudad y las
150.000 necesitan algún tipo de ayuda
algo psicológico algo humanitario
esta ciudad al sur de ucrania ha sido
objeto de bombardeos casi a diario desde
el inicio de la invasión rusa en febrero
por supuesto que la gente tiene miedo de
que los rusos avancen pero todos se
esperan que no nos alcancen y que las
cosas mejoren pero muchas casas en
nuestro pueblo están destruidas y la
gente a muerte beta mykolaiv está a
menos de 70 km de gerzón la urbe que
quedó bajo control ruso cinco meses
atrás la región de sap orilla es otro de
los blancos del kremlin este miércoles
cohetes rusos atacaron la zona lo que ha
encendido las alertas del organismo
internacional de energía atómica y ha
llevado al g7 a pedirle a rusia que
despeje el perímetro de la planta
nuclear más grande de europa por la
seguridad de la región exigimos que
rusia de inmediato el control total a su
propietario soberano legítimo ucrania de
la planta de energía nuclear de sabor y
jam así como de todas las instalaciones
nucleares dentro de las fronteras
internacionalmente reconocidas de
ucrania para garantizar sus operaciones
seguras
moscú y kiev se han culpado mutuamente
de los ataques que la central de sap
orilla recibió esta semana se le ha
pedido que se sancione la industria
nuclear de putin mientras que las tropas
rusas aseguran que fueron ellas las que
derribaron los drones ucranianos que se
acercaron a los reactores atómicos de la
central
españa comenzó a aplicar este miércoles
el decreto del gobierno para cumplir el
ahorro energético pactado con la unión
europea un decreto que ha recibido el
rechazo del principal partido de la
oposición que ha intentado frenarlo en
los tribunales sin éxito por el momento
la rebaja de la refrigeración en
empresas y dependencias públicas a los
27 grados en verano es uno de los puntos
que más polémica ha generado desde
barcelona- ampliamos con marina colorado
comienza la carrera de ahorro de gas del
7 establecido para españa' después del
acuerdo alcanzado con la unión europea
para
disminuir los efectos de la guerra en
ucrania en el país hoy miércoles 10 de
agosto entran en vigor algunas de las
restricciones impuestas por el gobierno
de pedro sánchez entre ellas el uso del
aire acondicionado y de la calefacción
el aire acondicionado durante los meses
de verano no podrá estar por debajo de
los 27 grados celsius aunque hay algunas
excepciones como por ejemplo en
restaurantes o en lugares como mercados
de comida donde la seguridad alimentaria
tiene que mantener una temperatura
definida y en los meses de invierno la
calefacción no podrá estar por encima de
los 19 grados además de estas
restricciones hoy también entra en vigor
el cierre el apagado perdón de los del
alumbrado en edificios públicos y de los
escaparates que a partir de las 10 de la
noche
tendrán que estar apagados siempre y
cuando no quede gente en su interior
estas medidas estarán en vigor hasta
noviembre del año que viene de 2000 el
30 de septiembre además entran otras
medidas en vigor como por ejemplo el
cierre de puertas en establecimientos
que no podrán dejar que la energía se
desperdicie tanto el aire acondicionado
como la calefacción por tener como por
ejemplo este establecimiento las puertas
abiertas tendrán que tener un sistema
aunque sea rudimentario para evitar el
despilfarro de energía aunque provenga
de fuentes renovables todo esto con
todas estas medidas de restricción el
gobierno de pedro sánchez pretende
reducir su consumo de gas entre un 4 y
un 5 por ciento
nos vamos al continente africano el
gobierno de sierra leona impuso un toque
de queda a nivel nacional ante las
violentas manifestaciones
antigubernamentales según las
autoridades a ella un número
indeterminado de muertes entre
manifestantes y uniformados el toque de
queda comenzó este miércoles desde las
tres de la tarde -hora local- las
protestas se dieron en medio de un
descontento generalizado contra el
gobierno y el alza del precio de los
productos básicos en un país con más de
la mitad de su población bajo el umbral
de la pobreza
y nos vamos a perú porque jennifer
paredes cuñada del presidente pedro
castillo ha sido declarada prófuga de la
justicia tras evadir una orden de
detención preliminar la fiscalía ordenó
buscarla en el palacio presidencial como
parte de las investigaciones por un caso
de lavado de activos el presidente acusó
a la fiscalía ya parte de la oposición
de querer quebrantar el orden
democrático nuestro corresponsal en lima
francisco zacarías no se amplia
jennifer paredes cuñada del presidente
pedro castillo es prófuga de la justicia
peruana por eso la fiscalía y un equipo
de la policía allanaron la casa del
mandatario que se encuentra en el centro
poblado de chugur en la región cajamarca
en la diligencia se cumplió la orden de
descerraje las autoridades ingresaron a
la vivienda pero no encontraron a
paredes su rebeldía a colaborar con la
justicia podría motivar a la fiscalía
ordenar una prisión preventiva contra
ella por nueve meses según algunos
expertos por su parte el presidente
pedro castillo durante una reunión con
representantes de rondas campesinas
arremetió nuevamente contra el congreso
y sus opositores a quienes acusó de
hacer creer a los peruanos que el
presidente ha robado al país y que su
círculo familiar es igual a otros que
según pedro casi o saquearon al perú
mientras tanto desde el parlamento se ha
solicitado al jefe de la casa militar
las imágenes de las cámaras de seguridad
que registran los accesos al palacio de
gobierno y la residencia presidencial en
paralelo la ex presidenta del congreso
maría del carmen alba a través de sus
redes sociales criticó a pedro casi o el
exigió dejar de obstaculizar a la
justicia y renunciar al cargo
y hablando de renuncias venid espinoza
abogado del presidente pedro castillo
renunció a seguir ejerciendo su defensa
he tomado la decisión de renunciar a la
defensa del señor presidente y la
primera dama reveló el abogado a través
de sus redes sociales pocos días después
de la toma de posesión del nuevo
presidente colombiano gustavo petro los
ministros de defensa de colombia y
venezuela hablaron sobre restablecer las
relaciones militares la cooperación en
este ámbito ha sido limitada desde 2019
cuando se rompieron las relaciones
diplomáticas entre las naciones
la elección de gustavo petro podría
marcar un punto de inflexión en las
relaciones entre venezuela y colombia
que se está trabajando la normalización
de las relaciones que es un proceso que
implica la apertura de las fronteras
cetera pocos días después de la
ceremonia de investidura de petro los
dos gobiernos han estado en contacto
expresando un deseo compartido de
cooperación militar a lo largo de los
2.200 kilómetros de frontera compartida
las relaciones se habían ido
deteriorando paulatinamente entre el
gobierno de maduro y el de colombia la
frontera ha estado casi completamente
cerrada desde 2015 ya que ambas partes
se acusan mutuamente de avivar la
inseguridad en una región conocida por
el narcotráfico y la violencia
guerrillera el presidente saliente de
colombia y bando que reconoció al líder
opositor juan guaidó como presidente
interino del estado vecino la elección
de petro por tanto ha sido bien recibida
por caracas nuevo escenario nacional que
vive en colombia en momento ya de
retomar
responsabilidades
y a trabajar en conjunto
por supuesto con las responsabilidades
diferenciadas
alegar que tenga previsto reunirse con
maduro en los próximos días petro
advirtió que hay varios asuntos
pendientes y que no se nombrará un
embajador en caracas hasta que se
normalizan las relaciones
anteriormente hablamos con víctor
mijares profesor de la universidad de
los andes en colombia quien nos contaba
cómo puede afectar este anuncio a la
migración venezolana en el país
pues lo primero y más fundamental desde
luego es la apertura no solamente la
embajada sino más importante que ellos
los consulados la población venezolana
que es de acuerdo a migración colombia
se estima que puede ya haber superado
los dos millones dos millones
cuatrocientos mil venezolanos en
territorio colombiano requieren por
supuesto de asistencia consular para sus
documentos para su vida cotidiana para
mantener entonces digamos un flujo
normal sobre todo esa población que
emigra pendularmente mantener también
control sobre sus bienes que mantiene
todavía algunos en venezuela- entonces
hay ahora una dinámica social
completamente nueva a partir de esto y
hace falta por supuesto esa asistencia
consular y del lado colombiano esa
participación esa asistencia consular
también es importante porque en la
medida en la cual se pueda identificar
plenamente los venezolanos pues habrán
mejores mecanismos de control sabiendo
que ha habido algunas controversias con
respecto a
actividades ilícitas en donde podrían
estar y donde se ha demostrado que ha
estado involucrados algunos migrantes
venezolanos
y hubo nueva jornada de movilizaciones
en argentina movimientos sociales de
izquierdas se manifestaron frente a la
casa rosada de buenos aires- la sede del
gobierno del país estos movimientos
reclaman mejoras sociales que declaran
urgentes y poder reunirse con el nuevo
ministro de economía a sergio massa la
intención de los manifestantes es
quedarse en la plaza de mayo- por tiempo
indeterminado hasta que el ministro les
dé una respuesta
y cerramos este informativo en paraguay
el ex presidente y senador del país
fernando lugo sufrió un accidente
cerebrovascular por el que permanece en
coma inducido así lo informó el
legislador jorge querey de la coalición
de izquierda a la que pertenece el líder
político y médico encargado de tratarlo
informó que el lugo presenta una lesión
relativamente pequeña
y hasta aquí este repaso informativo
sigan conectados a france 24 y a france
24 punto com
[Música]